-Bowen Yang, I want to talk
about your new movie,
"Fire Island,"
but this is true.
You just got back from --
from vacation.
-From vacation in Fire Island.
We went buck wild
and watched "The Hours,"
starring Nicole Kidman
and Meryl Streep
and Julianne Moore.
-Yeah, wait. Sorry.
-You said you went buck wild.
-I went buck wild.
-Fire Island is like party,
like -- [ Imitates air horn ]
Yeah, air horn.
-Air horn, but for us,
it was "Mrs. Dalloway
will get the flowers herself."
It was, like, very --
like, so -- we were going crazy
by watching "The Hours."
-You didn't go to high tea?
-We went to high tea,
but the highlight was really,
like,
people coming to our house,
thinking we were partying,
and then it was just
a dark living room with the glow
of Meryl Streep.
-Meryl Streep.
The glow of Meryl Streep.
-The glow of Meryl Streep.
-It's hard to beat that.
Well, you have
a very interesting thing.
I know it's the start of summer,
and I just want
to talk to you about this.
You are -- You have an issue
in a popular summer trend.
You are afraid of White Claw.
-I'm afraid of White Claw.
-That's on your IMDb page.
-[ Laughs ]
Yeah, it is.
-But why are you afraid
of that beverage?
-Here's the thing,
and go with me on this.
Because seltzer itself
is already too much.
It's like spicy bubbly water.
[ Laughter ]
And so to make it alcoholic
is just a hat on top of a hat,
right?
[ Laughter ]
And, like,
the cans are too tall,
and they're staring me down
in the fridge.
I still have White Claw
from last year in my fridge.
Everyone, stop!
Everyone's not on my side
with this.
-No, we're on your side!
-Come on! Boo!
-All right, all right!
-No, no, no.
We love White Claw.
-But have you tried it?
-I've tried it.
But I -- you know what?
-It's too much.
But I just heard that
the official drink of the summer
is a Dirty Shirley.
And I was drinking
Shirley Temples
way back in middle school
at Chili's or whatever.
-What is a --
-What is a Dirty Shirley?
It's a Shirley Temple with,
like, vodka in it or something.
-Wow.
-And so that's --
Aperol Sprtiz is over,
and now Dirty Shirleys are in,
and so I feel like
I'm ahead of the trend.
And...
-I mean...
-Speaking of
ahead of the trends...
-Oh!
-I saw you on the season finale.
By the way, another great season
of Bowen Yang,
"Saturday Night Live," huh?
Not too shabby.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Here you are, season finale
of "Saturday Night Live,"
the Trendsetters.
-Yes.
-Gosh, it made me laugh so much.
Is that Dirty --
-That might be a Dirty Shirley.
-Might be a Dirty Shirley.
-Definitely not a hard seltzer.
-No, definitely not.
[ Laughter ]
This was Aidy's last show.
-It was.
-It was Kate McKinnon's
last show,
it was Kyle Mooney's,
Pete Davidson.
-Like, four people who defined
what the show was so long.
-Was it emotional? I've been
there when people leave.
It's always --
For me, it's a little --
I feel like I just want to step
away and let them have their --
-Yeah.
I basically did that.
But I was still a jerk,
and at good-nights,
they were hugging,
and they probably imagined
what this moment would be like,
their last good-nights.
And I was just off to the side
but still, like,
sneaking a photo in.
I felt like such a --
such a paparazzi jerk.
Anyway, I mean, after that,
we just went to the after-party
and ate pigs in a blanket.
-Yeah, that's how you do it!
That's how you party.
-That's how you party, and Lorne
loves a pig in a blanket.
-He does?
-He likes -- Wait.
Didn't he --
I feel pigs in a blanket
is one of those Lorne lore
things that has been there
since, like,
the show has existed.
-Pigs in a blanket?
-What are you talking --
You know -- You know this.
-I know Lorne,
but I don't know
pigs in a blanket.
-Okay.
He loves pigs in a blanket.
-Well, who doesn't love
pigs in a blanket?
-There you go.
-I mean, right?
-Yeah!
-Popcorn I know,
but I didn't know about
pigs in a blanket.
-Pigs in a blanket.
That's, like, part of mythology.
The mythos of Lorne.
-I want to talk to you, also,
about this because...
[ Laughter ]
Speaking about Mr. Paparazzi,
taking photos and stuff.
No big deal.
Just Kim Kardashian
went up to you and said, "Bowen,
I need a picture with you."
-Yeah.
-And...
[ Cheers and applause ]
She got a photo with you,
and there's proof,
because it's actually
on her show.
-Yes!
-It was documented.
-Where she came up to me
and said,
"I'm gonna be so annoying.
Can I get a picture with you?"
And I --
-Tsss!
-Yeah.
-Just saying you're hot.
-Just saying I'm hot.
Like, I thought it was
the craziest thing of my life
that she wanted
something with me.
It was such a crazy night,
'cause our sketch got cut,
and she had so much fun in it.
And so I was, like,
truly down in the dumps,
and then she came and foisted me
back up into heaven.
-She's super fun.
-She's so nice!
-She is really nice.
She's a pro.
But then I also heard that
Dua Lipa and you had a bond.
-Yes.
-And at one point,
she said to you that you guys
were gonna get matching tattoos?
-Okay. This is her idea.
There's something about these
gorgeous women with dark hair
and middle parts
where they...
[ Laughter ]
...they really
gravitate toward me.
-Middle parts.
Okay. Yeah.
-We did this sketch together.
I wrote her into the sketch.
We named her character Marjorie.
And then, at good-nights,
I was complimenting her tattoos,
and she said,
"Let's get one together."
And it was truly, like,
an out-of-body experience.
And so she still
hasn't really --
The soft plan is,
we're gonna get it
the next time she's in New York.
But I feel like she's --
I feel like
she's blowing me off.
And so...
[ Laughter ]
...I do want to take this time
to address Miss Lipa.
-Yeah, sure.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
Dua...it was your idea.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
Don't make her uncomfortable.
-Dua, it's your old pal, Bowen.
-Yes.
-And I think we stumbled
on the idea which is
we're gonna get
matching Marjorie tattoos.
I will learn stick and poke,
or we can share the same needle.
Whatever you want to do,
let's make it --
-All right.
That's very controversial.
But thank you.
Dua, think about it.
-Think about it.
-Let's talk about "Fire Island."
-Yeah!
-Let's talk about this movie.
One of your best friends,
Joel Kim Booster, wrote this.
-Yep.
-Also stars in it.
Can you set up what
"Fire Island" is about?
It's on Hulu right now.
-It's on Hulu right now.
It's a modern retelling
of "Pride and Prejudice,"
by Jane Austin,
but it all takes place
in this queer vacation town,
Fire Island.
And I play the Jane Bennet.
I play the Rosamund Pike
of this film.
And it's so fun.
And you get all these
fun rom-com moments
that you never thought
you'd be able to do.
-I love -- I think Fire Island
is just gorgeous, too,
but I just love this.
And it is rom-com moments,
which I love romantic comedies.
But there's a karaoke scene.
-Uh-huh.
-There's a scene where you're
tripping and falling
into someone who's gorgeous.
You're like, "Bu-bu-bu-bu."
-You did that
in "Fever Pitch," right?
-I did that in every movie
I was in.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-I did that in "Jurassic Park."
-I was in "Jurassic World."
I tripped and fell
on a dinosaur, I go,
"Bu-bu-bu-bu-bu."
[ Laughter ]
I'm really good at that.
-Meet-cute.
-Yeah, exactly, total meet-cute.
But I don't know.
Like, pining after someone
in a movie
is really kind of fun, actually.
I recommend it to everybody.
[ Laughter ]
-To do that.
I want to show a clip.
Here's Bowen Yang
in "Fire Island."
Take a look at this.
-Baby, you don't need
a boyfriend.
You just need to learn
how to protect yourself
a little bit more, 'cause
all this romance bull [bleep]
is making you
way too vulnerable.
You're like an open wound.
-Yeah, but I want the romance
bull [bleep]
I like the rom-com stuff,
like...
kissing in the rain
and standing outside my window
with the boom box or confessing
things in a gazebo.
What's wrong with that?
-Nothing's wrong with that.
It's just [bleep] like that
doesn't happen in real life.
The only real thing
is you and me.
[Bleep] the rest.
♪♪
-Fine.
If you're so invested in this,
I will try and get laid.
-Yes!
-Yeah, "Fire island."
-Yeah.
-Congrats on everything.
I thought that we'd maybe toast.
-Oh!
-With maybe a pig in a blanket!
-Whoa!
Pigs in a blanket!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Cheers, buddy.
-Cheers.
-Best of luck with everything.
I love you.
Bowen Yang!
"Fire Island"
is streaming now on Hulu.